boa tarde a todos
a desconexão laranja mecânica como ela
falou meu nome é rachid e eu faço parte
de um movimento chamado hip hop faz uma
música chamada rep é tenho 28 anos nasci
em 1988 logo eu pertenço à geração y
está ligado
provavelmente a última geração na
história da humanidade é saber o que foi
uma vida 100% sem internet
muito louco isso ver a evolução das
coisas
fiz questão de falar que faço parte de
um movimento chamado hip hop porque
primeiro a minha raiz mas também para
esclarecer um pouco na cabeça de vocês
qual a diferença entre o rap é o hip hop
e pra falar porque o hip hop se tornou a
minha primeira rede a minha primeira
conexão com o mundo no primeiro vai faz
chame do que quiser ter negado
acho que várias pessoas aqui já tiveram
algum tipo de contato com a música rap
nem que seja esse aqui o primeiro estão
tendo o que as pessoas não sabem é que o
rap ele pertence ao hip hop na relva
ele faz parte do hip hop e nós chamamos
o hip hop de movimento porque trata se
de um movimento cultural que engloba
quatro elementos oms que é isso aqui que
vos fala é o cara que canta é o cara que
está na linha de frente pode ser haxixe
pode ser a nossa mestre de cerimônia
também porque ms
significa isso mestre de cerimônias que
a sigla significa pode ser humano brown
ou pode ser o raul gil também em ms
a gente tem o dj o dj é o cara que solta
a batida para os répteis e mar em acho
que diana é um elemento mais comum as
pessoas estão acostumadas
na balada
tá hoje em dia tende até de sertanejo
chega lá têm até hoje dia que toca com
os apoios do equipamento desligado
também acontece a gente tem o break
o break que é a dança da parada quando
você vai no lugar você liga a tv tem
aquele cara fazendo aquele espaço de
dança muito louco
gian de cabeça pra baixo dando mortal e
você fala irmão se fosse eu a coluna já
estava travada e as pessoas que dançam
break são conhecidas como boys
o big girls e realmente parece difícil e
realmente é muito difícil já tentei
também mas é bom hoje eu faço rima então
eu acho que isso quer dizer alguma coisa
a gente tem um grafite também é
importante primeiro diferencial grafite
e aplicação são coisas diferentes
é importante colocar na cabeça de todo
mundo também o grafite é muito
trabalhado
a gente tem muitas cores personagens
técnica 3d sobreposição sombra não sei o
que inclusive os grafiteiros que é como
são chamados os escritores de grafite os
grafiteiros brasileiros são mundialmente
famosos mundialmente famosos são paulo é
uma cidade referência quando a questão é
grafite e é muito louco como as pessoas
às vezes ainda enxergam grafite como
vandalismo mas acho que no momento os
mais famosos da atualidade são gêmeos
o gêmeo simplesmente foram contratados
foram pagos pra falar pra grafitar um
palácio se não me engano na escócia e os
gêmeos simplesmente foram contratados
para grafitar um avião da azul
se não me engano também enfim é eles
estão com uma exposição em nova york
agora que artistas monstruosos vão lá
pra ver o trabalho dos caras de emissões
são incríveis
assim como vários outros brasileiros do
grafite também mas é louco como no mundo
inteiro os gêmeos são reconhecidos desse
jeito aí alguns anos atrás não é na
gestão do nosso saudoso kassab em são
paulo eles apagaram um grafite
gigantesco do g1
a gente olha nossa como é legal palácio
na escócia grafitado pelos gêmeos mas
aqui na minha parede não apaga a pagar
foi embora
só que tudo isso que a gente vê se pára
separado por aí
todos esses elementos esses quatro
elementos vale a pena ressaltar que o
mcce o de juntos eles fazem a música rap
por isso que eu digo que o rap está
dentro do hip hop é todos esses
elementos que a gente vê por aí fazem
parte da mesma coisa
fazem parte da mesma parada e são
funcionários da mesma empresa que
prestam serviços diferentes e únicos
a brigada é voltando ao aveia principal
se a gente for puxar no fundamento das
coisas obviamente a nossa família ea
escola são as nossas primeiras conexões
ali são as nossas primeiras redes sem
fio vamos dizer onde a gente se conecta
com pessoas desconhecidas entre aspas e
a partir daí a gente passa a ter um laço
mas o hip hop na minha vida foi a
primeira rede que me conectar ou a
pessoas do outro lado do mundo pessoas
ao redor do mundo no japão ou até num
país vizinho em que a gente tem tanta
dificuldade de comunicação embora a
gente mora um doador que está ligado o
hip hop me conectar essas pessoas
simplesmente pelo fato de acreditarmos
nos mesmos ideais escutarmos a mesma
música pensarmos na mesma direção
nos vestimos do mesmo jeito aquela calça
cair no gigante com a camiseta cinco
extra g que a nossa mãe odiava
para sorte da nossas mães essa fase
passou pelo menos do haxixe
posso entender também até porque não
deve ser fácil lavar uma camiseta que
cabe cinco filhos eu poderia estar ali
cobrindo a família inteira no sofá
é a camiseta que isso uma eleição a
camisa do michel nova era mais ou menos
isso tinha umas mangas que vem até aqui
e eu achava que era muito bonita mas a
arte também está
nuno life style a gente tem que saber
isso
e a gente se vestia escutava música
pensar do mesmo jeito mas a gente nunca
tinha trocar ideia antes nunca tinha
trocar idéia isso bem antes da internet
pra você ver o hip hop conectando as
pessoas acredito que cada um tem a sua
própria parada na sua vida que se
conecta a outras pessoas
fora a internet fora o celular e tudo
mais
e nessa rede existe uma troca fazia bem
à ela como adepto e ela me fazia bem
eu lutava sua luta você lutava minha
luta união por isso que eu chamo essa
parada de rede pegada e depois ao longo
dos anos depois de descobrir a minha
verdadeira vocação no hip hop não era
dança
eu tentei e grafiteiro também é até hoje
o desenho está desenhando ali numa folha
livro colocar para a exposição pra vocês
mentira é o desenho até hoje tão mas
enfim descobrir a rima verdadeira
vocação do haxixe
depois de participar de várias batalhas
de improviso que é aquela batalha em que
você coloca 2006 frente a frente cada um
tem que fazer a rima atacando o outro
ali do ano usando característica física
o que o cara estava vestindo e tudo mais
nas batalhas e que eu participar varão
para proibido determinado tipo de de
tema também não podia chegar lá e falar
pô cara vou pegar você sua irmã sua tia
não vale este tipo de rima não não valia
e inclusive na rinha dos mcs que é uma
das batalhas grandes que a gente
participava não podia falar nem palavrão
cara falava palavrão ele já era
desclassificado na hora de cortar uma
batida ponto desce do palco já era então
a gente tinha que realmente força a
nossa criatividade a fazer algo
interessante
depois de participar dessas batalhas
depois de lançar o cd mix tape e como
ela falou aqui em cima depois de lançar
nossa loja virtual que veio acompanhado
também na nossa produtora chamada foco
na missão
aí já o lado empreendedor do haxixe jael
assunto para outro pedetista
tá ligado depois de fazer essas coisas
chegou o ponto nesse ano que eu lancei
meu primeiro álbum oficial chamado a
coragem da luz
nesse disco tem uma música específica
chamada laranja mecânica eu acredito que
essa música é um fator crucial para que
eu esteja aqui hoje falando sobre
desconexão com vocês ela fala sobre o
desenvolvimento tecnológico sobre a
nossa dependência em relação às
tecnologias também é basicamente sobre o
presente e um olhar pro futuro
só que ela é inspirada em três grandes
obras literárias do passado
laranja mecânica de anthony burgess diz
é o livro mesmo sei que tem um filme do
clube que mais foi inspirado no livro
1984 e à revolução dos bichos de george
orwell primeiro já sei que muita gente
já se espanta e pensa em saber que o rap
busca informação entanto as fontes há
sim
e realmente é isso que acontece desde
sempre
segundo quem leu os três livros ou algum
deles e sabe mais ou menos o que
acontece nos outros
imagina que é uma mistura um pouco
perigosa
imagina que é uma receitinha inocente
para um coquetel molotov tipos e é
realmente eu tinha acabado de ler os
três vivem na mesma época e virou meio
que uma salada monstra na minha cabeça
tá ligado
o comportamento violento da juventude ea
lavagem cerebral que rola no laranja
mecânica mas a paranóia e o grande irmão
vigiando a gente o tempo todo que rola
no 1984 e a certeza absoluta que uma
hora tudo vai sair do controle vai dar
uma grande merda como acontece na
revolução dos bichos é isso tudo se
misturou e nasceu o primeiro verso da
música laranja mecânica que diz assim
onde as flores morre de sede e crianças
de fome
o descaso para ti um drone por todo
canto feito grande irmão e o progresso é
uma mentira mal pintada implorando mais
uma demão século laranja mecânica
babilônica e ator messiânica tv no
glamour e na riqueza os poderes de herói
e o amor na prateleira com selo da
tectoy é como a praga na colheita que
roy multidão igual os presos na
indonésia caminhando rumo a execução com
amnésia a ponto de não saber como era
sua vida sem 3g um ser humano gelli do
fim iludido o manequim exposição de um
produto que já foi vendido e o coração
abduzido quem nunca se encontrou também
não tem como saber que está perdida
[Aplausos]
além dos livros o que me levou a
escrever essa música é foi a reflexão
também de porque as pessoas estão
ficando cada vez mais mergulhado na
internet mergulhada na rede cada vez
mais fora de si consequentemente na
minha visão e na minha visão também a
resposta é simples simples porque a vida
parece muito melhor na internet chapa
pelo menos absurda tipo hoje sábado à
tarde ensolarado em indaiatuba de
repente você pa
ainda no instagram no facebook snapfish
uma pessoa um amigo seu
é sempre assim seu melhor amigo sei lá
um churrasco
o outro na beira da piscina o outro tá
no shopping no cinema
outro está viajando está na times square
em nova york
o outro time machu picchu e você fala
irmão só eu fiquei em casa vendo o game
of thrones rafael assim a vida de todo
mundo é melhor que a minha não é
possível treinar e eu acho que essa
necessidade de mostrar que você faz
coisas da hora na vida coisas legais que
ninguém mostra as agruras também na
internet ninguém possa lá o mano hoje
meu dia meu deus é a ostentação de
sofrimento ninguém ninguém ninguém
mostra e acho que tanto na necessidade
de mostrar que você faz coisas legais na
vida quanto a de encontrar alguém que
esteja tão na força quanto você talvez é
que mantém agente preso ali na internet
telhado foi você acordar
a primeira coisa você põe à mostra assim
você tateia o criado-mudo olha o celular
romano
antigamente nós acordava né pivete
acordava já acordava com a roupa de sair
é praticamente já descia pegava um pão
já saía com a cara na rua comendo pão
ainda nem pensar duas vezes
hoje em dia é aquela passada na internet
tudo mais - eu queria dizer que
videogame ainda que a pouco tá escurecer
no jamor
ninguém sai para a rua mais ligada e
acho que essas coisas mantêm a gente lá
preso nas redes sociais
eu não posso reclamar não por quê
o meu trabalho foi basicamente espalhado
pelas redes sociais
sabe a gente conseguiu chegar nas
pessoas e tudo mais
ali onde a gente mantém o contato direto
com os fãs
isso é lindo lindo só que a gente
aprendeu rapidinho também que a gente
não pode se basear naquilo para tudo
terminado por exemplo a gente tem uma
página no facebook com mais de mais de
um milhão de pessoas e isso quer dizer
que todos os shows do haxixe vão ser
soldado timon tais go tados os ingressos
não a gente sabe que não
a gente tem uma página no facebook com
mais de um milhão de pessoas mas isso
quer dizer que todas as músicas que a
gente lançar vão ter mais de um milhão
de visualizações e todos os clipes vão
bombar na rede ter mais de um milhão de
visualizações também não mas a gente se
ligou que isso aí é incrível os números
são incríveis no currículo no release
só que na prática eles iludem e eles
enganam se você não cativar as pessoas
de verdade você não fazer as pessoas se
movimentarem você não fazer seus fãs
sei lá seu público-alvo sei lá sair para
a rua
no meu caso se não fizer as pessoas
comprarem a camiseta é com consumirem a
música comprar os ingressos para os
shows irem ao show está ligado
se não fizer isso de nada adianta todos
esses números ea gente aprendeu que a
gente tem que fazer as pessoas
interagirem na vida real também
e é bom para elas também porque eu sei
que vários casais já se formaram no show
do haxixe inclusive já ligaram rachid o
cupido do rap nacional
mas é realmente tem que trazer as
pessoas para a rua delegado tem que
trazer para a rua porque é o seguinte eu
penso assim as nossas ideias elas têm
que valer alguma coisa na rua e que vale
muita coisa nossa troca de idéia no
almoço num passeio enfim mas às vezes as
coisas acabam ficando virando farofa
como a gente fala popularizando mauá as
nossas idéias acabam virando farol a
fama porque as pessoas às vezes na rede
social as distribuem tanto a opinião
graça alegado que a pessoa acaba virando
uma chata manhã o chato do rolê
você tá lá de boa e vem chegando a
pessoa seja uma semana lá venta e depois
daquele texto de hoje irmão a pessoa
sei lá explode uma bomba não sei onde a
pessoa vai lá e faz um texto tão assunto
seriíssimo beleza é você de boa e até le
aí sei lá aumenta a condução não sei
onde a pessoa vai lá e faz um texto você
falar ó pessoa engajada mas dessa vez é
só olhar as três primeira linha a e
beleza neymar pintou o cabelo de novo aí
a pessoa vai fazer um festão se fala pô
máximo ultrapassando os limites não
votei que bloquear ou vou ter que
bloqueava a e sem lama orangotango
pianista lança a música ea pessoa vai lá
e faz um texto não se fala irmão ano a
não ser que você seja muito fã de
segurança o tango que essa notícia séria
feita fazendo encerrada mas está fazendo
errado para com isso acho um barato bem
louco de está escrito na internet lá
aliás está escrito não mas se você
pensar toda vez que entro na internet é
nem que perguntou nada
pensei isso toda vez que entrar lá em
vez de estar escrito no twitter lá ou no
facebook escreveu aquilo que você está
pensando nisso aí a brecha que o sistema
kerigma a pessoa tá ali tipo a escreva
que você está pensando é falar é hoje
céu pouco teve até escrito lá ninguém
pediu sua opinião as coisas serão
melhores mas as coisas vão ser mais da
hora se tivesse escrito sair porque as
pessoas a pensar real médio é vou pegar
leve o grande amigo meu uma vez
me falou mano
a gente é muito abençoado porque a gente
tem um público que escuta o que a gente
fala se identifica vai nos shows e tudo
mais mas a verdade também haxixe é que
ninguém nunca pediu nossa opinião cara
eu falei é verdade mas nunca tinha
pensado dessa forma eu faço música e
falando de tudo quanto é coisa ninguém
nunca pediu minha opinião é verdade
quando você possa pensar e se começa a
valorizar mais as pessoas que se
identificam com suas idéias você começa
a valorizar mais a sua própria opinião
talhadas e falar
peraí vou seguir vou dar uma segurada
nesse texto tão aqui porque é muito
louco comum em plena 2016
o racismo continua se espalhando junto
com o machismo homofobia xenofobia
também empregado e é a rede que espalha
tanta coisa da hora pra gente que tem
espalhado essas coisas também sabe
só que tudo isso tudo isso tem um efeito
muito grande na vida real mas na vida
real coloca a autoestima das pessoas lá
no chão tá ligado traz à tona a
depressão ansiedade violência e garante
com que as próximas gerações continuem
machistas racistas homofóbicas ao passo
que a gente tem tentado lutar contra
tudo está ligado
então eu acho que realmente a gente tem
que começar a pensar e ser a valorizar
nossas idéias valorizar nossas opiniões
tudo isso que eu falei aqui também podia
ser resumida em duas palavras por
detalhar bom senso já era talhado aí
resumiu a palestra do haxixe foi
incrível da hora achei bom senso isso
mesmo vamos fazer até camiseta escrito
bom senso certo e só que para combater
essas coisas aí a gente pode até fazer
questão sobre esses assuntos que eu
falei é que pode fazer mas a gente
precisa de mais do que isso a gente
precisa de postura séria atitude firme
isso a gente só demonstra que na vida
real mas na vida real onde não tem
perfil anônimo certo direct message é
olho no olho
bate papo é mais legal a foto não engana
se visualiza ter que responder se quiser
mencionar fala na minha cara se passou
vergonha não esquenta não quer pagar
mais rápido que pôde no inep chade
a desvantagem é que não dá para bloquear
ninguém mas melhor do que mandar foto
pra todo mundo é você poder viver o
momento junto e também para aqueles e
aquelas que gostam dilma
luddy posso garantir que é mais difícil
de conseguir na vida real porém é muito
mais satisfatório rapaziada
caso contrário é só cabeças baixas cada
qual no seu aplicativo geração 60 de
conexão com que é vivo e no processo
evolutivo homem continua sendo um único
animal que mata sem motivo pegou no
crivo chip no cérebro frios como mármore
daqueles que só vêm os prédios esquecem
das árvores síndrome taticamente na
nuvem traz sequelas deduz que não tocam
peles apenas telas fácil como um
pendrive novo ea causa van de mostrar
como sua vida é boa no instagram
trincheira onde os racista e homofóbico
acumulam light pro seu ódio burro
ideológico sujo é lógico machismo dos
pms em leme
hoje você se tornou meme preso a um cabo
sp
sem querer se soltar e sem ver que a
vida não dá pra reiniciar
muito obrigado minha gente fica com deus
foco na missão valeu em
[Aplausos]